[Music]
hmm two pawns
a lot of possibilities somebody slap me
for that
[Applause]
a little break before we get into start
of series six proper space and time to
shorts that had basically formed one
coherent story they were part of it was
comic relief or red-nosed a contributing
to comic relief that sort of thing and
that's worth specifying because doctor
who has done specials for that as well
as children in need and it's important
to recognize which are which because I
wanted to be certain to go back and
double-check this because after watching
I'm like I hope that wasn't a children
or need special because if it was that
would have been part of my assessment
because I would have gone not exactly
kid mm-hmm super friendly um that said I
it's weird I feel like whenever I hear
this little story I'm gonna refer to it
as one thing even those two halves
whenever I hear this talk about it
always seems to be fairly derisive lis
and maybe it just happens to click with
my sense of humor I actually I have a
lot of fun with this thing it's like
it's fluff it it is very clear from the
get-go that it is full off
so there's not a lot of weight to be put
on it so there's this whole thing of the
doctor you know working on the TARDIS
and worries helping and I first of all I
kind of like that I kind of like the
idea that Rory's trying to be helpful
and there is a distraction that causes
Rory to drop something and then things
go very very wrong now I mentioned that
this would have been fairly
inappropriate if this had been on
children in need and that starts right
off the bat with the distraction the
reason Rory got distracted is because
he's working down below underneath the
glass floor and Amy was standing above
him in a very short skirt and I suspect
jokes like that are maybe part of why
there's some derision towards this
particular one off I for my part I don't
find it particularly egregious I mean
take
that you know for whatever you feel it's
worth coming from me versus you know
from other people but I for me amongst
other things it's incredibly consistent
with the characterization of a me in the
nature of Amy and Rory's relationship
and it doesn't feel like things have
been twisted out of character
it does fields or certainly sound like
this is the kind of moment that maybe we
wouldn't normally get not just because
it you know it wouldn't move the plot
along but also because it is a little
bit more risque this the some of the
notes in this overall and maybe being
part of comic relief they felt they
could get away with that more but it
doesn't feel inconsistent with the
characters or what I would imagine their
lives and the TARDIS would be like it's
just the kind of thing we don't normally
see so when Rory drops whatever it is
suddenly the TARDIS materializes inside
of the TARDIS and so inside the console
room is a TARDIS and if they go through
the doors they come in the door of the
TARDIS and they are theoretically
possibly stuck there forever and that
gives us into this wonderful little bit
of time loop and paradox stuff which
obviously Moffat likes to play with and
he likes to toy with this sort of
intertwining of time and doing things
that don't make a ton of sense I mean
that's a big part of what blink is that
was a big part of the payoff had in the
big bang he enjoys doing this sort of
stuff and I actually really liked that
he did it in something light and fluffy
like this and created a situation where
something's going wrong as a TARDIS to
basically justify a paradox happening
because normally paradox is not supposed
to be a thing that can happen so you
know having it just be linked to the
fact that something is very wrong here
that works well for me and I again you
know maybe it's something that that
throws people off but you know Amy
flirting with herself again speaking
personally I buy that you know when a
slightly future version of Amy comes
with the door suddenly there's two Amy's
in the room
first of all I've again I think it it's
all again I find it all very consistent
with a me as a character that
she has this kind of double standards
that she will flirt with herself but
like she'll smack Rory for entertaining
the notion of two Amy's so you know that
the kind of double standard that's yeah
that's kind of heard that there is an
inherent power imbalance with her
relationship with Rory there always has
been that was there from the get-go
and just give all we know about Amy
you know and what her life has been like
and ya know I would totally buy that she
would see herself and basically go ooh
hello between you know her her own
feelings about herself and she seems
like just a very open-minded person so
like I can go with that and just like I
said overall I find this thing just fun
it moves at a good pace it keeps the
jokes coming so even if a joke doesn't
land especially well there's another one
coming in a little bit maybe that one
will work better for you and like that I
see rather frequently an awful lot of
criticisms about Moffitt's handling of
female characters and my I don't know if
I'll ever dedicate a video to that but
my own general assessment is he relies
on similar patterns and templates much
more than he should
but speaking personally I I usually in
the context that they appear enjoy a
pretty decent I enjoy his female
characters more often than I don't like
I still enjoy coupling you know when
it's is it a reductive view of sexual
dynamics well yeah for both men and
women but within the context of what
it's doing
I find it entertaining and I find that
the case for a lot of Moffitt's
female characterizations even the ones
that I see him get criticized for I will
grant though that he leans on certain
things
a little bit more than he should in
terms of certain archetypes and he seems
to have a much wider variety of male
character templates than he does female
ones but I've kind of gone off on a
tangent maybe I'm just trying to fill
time because like I said I feel like
people talk about this derisive Lee and
I just have fun with it I just enjoy it
about the only thing that I can say
about it that annoys me is and there was
no way around this they were gonna come
up with a Wow there was a way around it
but there was only so much they could do
is the music because they obviously
weren't going to create music
specifically for this but they use like
especially at the end the tail end of I
am the doctor you know the Denton
tenten's in it it's like you know it's
this big bombastic and it's like but we
just ended this weird quirky little
jaunt of an episode why why are the
horns blaring huh what stop so you know
that doesn't work
but that for me that's about the only
thing that doesn't really work for me
and I mean I like I'm biased I'm gonna
be biased in this thing's favor I love
this team I love this trio I love Matt
Smith's doctor Amy Pond and Rory
Williams those three together I think
are a fantastic trio they have a great
dynamic with each other every element
and all of the connections I think are
great Amy with Rory Amy with the doctor
the doctor with Rory the doctor but I
mean like everybody everybody's
relationships all the connections they
are all terrific and I love them and so
I enjoy this space in time Yuri watched
it lately whatever your thoughts are on
it drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff to do as well if you like
what I do maybe consider supporting me
on patreon that would be a massive help
there's a link for that down in the
description but even if you don't want
to do that you can still help me out
anyways by commenting liking subscribing
sharing the video all things which is
cysts in appeasing the algorithm because
if we do not it will destroy us all
but you don't have to I got a little
hyperbolic there but at the end of the
day look you're the council
I'm just running the meetings until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]